[Music]
everyone should have a stiff drink in
some and some counselling ready to go
The Handmaid's Tale season 2 finale is
officially here and leaves us with a
major cliffhanger
call her Nicole
[Music]
tell her I love her
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Jun decided not to leave Gilead
with Emily she makes a big decision at
the end of this when you read what her
decision was what was your reaction I
thought it was the only way to go you
know it's surprising it's definitely
shocking you're getting out of Juliet
I'm just dying to know what happens
first of all I can't believe that she's
gonna leave and then how does that work
you know I mean I know we saw June
escape and I wonder if it's going to be
similar or is it gonna happen all the
way like will she really get it leaves
us in a place where we're right back to
our thematic for the year the motherhood
and Gilead is within us maybe you can
get out you never get away we can get
you out
you and the baby but you have to go
right now go get your suicide who's
we've read is a gangster you get June
off out with the baby and then she
sticks around what is wrong with you I
got my girlfriend to smuggle you out
what's your problem I mean I love I love
the way it ended but at the same time
don't come back I'm not getting you out
again I did it once I think that people
are gonna have a hard time with it for
sure but I think that if you if you know
her and you know the fight that she sort
of has before her it'll make sense
kind of community is it safe to say she
makes that decision for Hannah I think
she makes it for all of her honestly all
the children that need to go back to
their family what do you think June's
decision at the end of the finale means
for her and Nick that's a really good
question I in this relationship I
believe in the two of them but I could
be optimistic and overly romantic so
we'll see what happens now
June's choice wasn't the only shocker
from the season two finale it's like I
cut out your tongue Emily made a choice
too when you read that what's happening
what went through your head I could not
believe it
like can you do that - um Lydia she's
like I'm really scared of the
repercussions from that I think that
aunt Lydia is somewhat indestructible so
I'm not as that confident about it I
think his home maybe Elizabeth is on to
something there here's a season three
spoiler alert for you video survives
Lydia survives okay we can put that out
there and kill Lydia No and then there
was Serena Joy's punishment
I think it's just it's a little too late
though it's it so much the pathetic move
to kind of go to stand before the
council and to what she does and it's
it's beautiful but it's pathetic at the
same time it's just so sad will she ever
truly return to the good side you know
will she we should go there what will it
take I always wondered what would happen
if she lost her one sort of hope which
is this baby that she holds on to you
know what kind of a person does she
become them because what's the whole
reason why she invested in in Gilead in
the first place so that's you know I
wonder we'll see is there going to be
like a wife aunt
hand-made Martha like Alliance where we
just go bananas and kill everybody and
when not kill you kill yeah killer yeah
destruction on some level
[Applause]
[Music]